[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
standing ovations im us kongress für
einen präsidenten im krieg der fast
flehentlich sagte in der dunkelsten zeit
für unser land ganz europa rufe ich sie
auch mehr zu tun
guten abend zum heute-journal selensky
wurde gegenüber den amerikanern auch
konkret er bat um mehr sanktionen mehr
waffen flugzeuge
luftabwehrsysteme aber wie weit die
militärische unterstützung gehen soll
und gehen kann darüber sind sich die
nato staaten durchaus uneins wie beim
treffen ihrer verteidigungsminister
heute deutlich wurde einigkeit herrscht
aber darüber dass sich die nato neu
ausrichten muss allen voran die europäer
darüber habe ich vorhin auch mit dem
früheren bundesaußenminister joschka
fischer gesprochen dazu kommen wir
später erst berichtet florian neuhann
über die entwicklungen dieses tages
sie haben es wieder heraus geschafft aus
kiew erst mit dem zug dann mit dem
dienstwagen schließlich mit dem flieger
drei regierungschefs aus polen
tschechien und slowenien an diesem
vormittag zurück von einem kurztrip in
den krieg was sie mitbringen ein paar
fotos mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
und eine idee die noch schlagzeilen
machen wird an diesem tag
ich denke in diesem konflikt ist eine
friedensmission nötig etwa unter führung
der nato oder in anderen internationalen
strukturen eine mission die in der lage
ist sich selbst zu verteidigen auf
ukrainischem territorium
was kann was soll die nato tun erstmals
seit ausbruch des kriegs treffen sich
die verteidigungsminister der allianz in
brüssel die zahl der masken zeigt dass
die eine große krise keine große rolle
mehr zu spielen scheint die andere dafür
umso mehr
doch eine nato mission in der ukraine
undenkbar für die meisten
wir unterstützen diese so mutigen
ukrainer in ihrem kampf gegen russland
wir müssen aber auch mit kühlem kopf
darauf achten dass dieser krieg nicht zu
einem krieg der nato wird
dieser krieg geht auch heute weiter ein
angriff auf ein boden gebäude in kiew am
morgen zivile opfer fast im ganzen land
und ein russischer präsident der derweil
vermeldet
die operation entwickelt sich
erfolgreich in strikter übereinstimmung
mit den vorab genehmigten plänen und das
alles passt nicht zu meldungen bei den
friedensverhandlungen mit der ukraine
gebe es fortschritte und so will man
sich darauf bei der nato auch nicht
verlassen sondern reagiert zum beispiel
mit weiteren waffen für die ukraine am
abend findet der us-präsident dafür
erneut 800 millionen us-dollar und
pathetische worte
es geht hier um freiheit und das recht
von völkern über ihre zukunft zu
bestimmen es geht darum sicherzustellen
dass die ukraine niemals ein sieg sein
wird für putin egal wer auf dem
schlachtfeld vorankommt und auch die
eigene verteidigung will die nato massiv
ausbauen mit militär in osteuropa
100.000 us soldaten sind schon jetzt in
europa stationiert weitere 40.000 aus
verschiedenen staaten unter nato
kommando
dabei hatten sich nato und russland 1997
geeinigt die nato weder auf dem gebiet
des ehemaligen ostblocks keine truppen
dauerhaft stationieren doch diese nato
russland grund akte galt im
gegenwärtigen und vorhersehbaren
sicherheitsumfeld das habe sich eben
geändert
damals haben wir uns dann noch als
strategischen partner gesehen das weiß
dem ist russland in georgien
einmarschiert hat illegal die krim
annektiert und jetzt die ukraine
angegriffen
[Musik]
es ist ein balance-akt für die nato sie
ergreift partei in diesem krieg aber
will bloß nicht selbst zur kriegspartei
werden
die nato richtet sich jedenfalls auf
harte zeiten ein die weltorganisation
wmo hingegen wird wohl auf lange zeit
gelähmt sein wie im vergangenen kalten
krieg da war der un sicherheitsrat ja
auch regelmäßig durch das veto der
sowjets oder durch das video dagegen
gegenseite beschlussunfähig irgendwelche
un-friedensmission wird es da auch nur
geben wenn moskau es will den vereinten
nationen bleibt im wesentlichen hier nur
eine moralische kraft so hat der
internationale gerichtshof das höchste
gericht der vereinten nationen heute
angeordnet dass russland den krieg
sofort beendet der ball putins truppen
weiter bombardieren und schwerster
kriegsverbrechen bezichtigt werden
besonders furchtbar ist die lage in der
hafenstadt mario pohl was uns von dort
an bildern und informationen erreicht
fasst ulrike rödl zusammen
in diesem krankenhaus in mario pohl gibt
es zu viele verletzte und zu viele tote
der ukrainische arzt weil er riet ringer
macht trotzdem weiter obwohl er
eigentlich nicht mehr kann das
schlimmste für ihn ist wenn er den babys
nicht mehr helfen kann so wie diese
neugeborenen
diese kinder kamen alle in den letzten
tagen dieses hier erst vergangenen
sonntag sie waren noch am leben als sie
gebracht wurden doch wir konnten sie
nicht retten
mittlerweile weiß er nicht mehr wohin
mit den vielen toten und verletzten die
meisten krankenhäuser in der region
seien zerbombt worden erzählt er über
2.300 zivilisten sollen seit
kriegsbeginn in mario pohl getötet
worden sein
es gibt keine rettungswagen merkt keiner
der hier etwas organisiert ich weiß auch
nicht wohin mit all den toten es gibt
keine verwandten die sich kümmern und
die leichenhalle nimmt keine toten mehr
an
ein stockwerk über ihn warten die
verletzten es werden jeden tag mehr dr
drängler und sein team müssen ihm jetzt
helfen doch es fehlen medikamente und
wichtige medizinische geräte
sich das an diese kinder waren in einem
gebäude das angegriffen wurde scheiben
fielen auf sie herab dann brachten wir
sie hier ins krankenhaus wenn dieser
brutkasten hier ausfällt dann was das
die stadt mario pohl am asowschen meer
etwa 60 kilometer von der russischen
grenze entfernt gilt als entscheidend
für einen versuch putins einen
landkorridor bis zur annektierten
halbinsel krim herzustellen deshalb ist
die stadt seit kriegsbeginn eine der am
heftigsten getroffenen offenbar haben
russische truppen die hafenstadt bereits
umzingelt und sind in der stadt bilder
davon gibt es nicht
immerhin konnten gestern 20.000
einwohner von mario pohl aus der stadt
flüchten vor wenigen stunden denn die
nachricht ein weiterer konvoi sei heute
unter beschuss geraten dr drängler und
sein team geben ihr bestes auch wenn das
oft nicht reicht
eigentlich ist man als arzt vieles
gewohnt aber diese bilder hier werde ich
nicht mehr aus dem kopf bekommen
unterdessen gehen die bombardierungen
weiter vor wenigen stunden ist dieses
theater in mario pohl zerstört worden
hier sollen hunderte menschen schutz
gefunden haben
und der frühere bundesaußenminister
joschka fischer ist uns zugeschaltet aus
köln von der lit.cologne wo er heute
abend über krieg und frieden ausspricht
und herr fischer
und
russland bombardiert die ukraine quasi
in schutt und asche die städte und das
land schreit verzweifelt um hilfe um die
nato sagt bis auf waffenlieferungen aus
sind uns die hände gebunden
wie geht es ihnen damit diesem drama
zuzusehen
da ist natürlich herzzerreißend wenn man
die bilder sieht wenn man die berichte
der flüchtlinge hört
und
nichts tun kann wirklich und insofern
ist
das emotional eine sehr deprimierende
situation
da sterben geht
ungebrochen weiter und man kann nur
hoffen dass
der krieg bald zu einem ende kommt und
in einem für beide seiten
tragbaren kompromiss
sehen sie dafür den anhaltspunkte ist
das jetzt überhaupt der moment wo dann
tatsächlich diplomatie schon wieder eine
chance hat russland scheint ja weiter zu
machen und auch weitermachen zu wollen
ich
weiß es nicht da müssen sie die
konfliktparteien fragen aber es ist eine
hoffnung und insofern
solidarität ist das gebot der stunde ich
finde sehr wichtig dass wir
als europäische union die grenzen
geöffnet haben dass unsere bevölkerung
die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine mit
großer emotion
aufnimmt und empfängt aber es bleibt
natürlich die tatsache dass das morden
dort weitergeht sie sagten eben man kann
nichts tun konnte die nato denn
tatsächlich nicht auch mehr tun ich
meine moment werden wir alle von putin
erpresst
schauen sie frau slomka ich denke dass
es die nato und die beteiligten
regierungen bisher eine sehr vernünftige
position vertreten nämlich einerseits
volle solidarität mit der ukraine auf
der anderen seite aber auch das wissen
darum dass russland einen der größten
nuklearmächte
weltweit ist und dass deswegen auch die
nötige umsicht und vorsicht geboten ist
also im prinzip haben die atomwaffen die
zur zeit des kalten krieges zur
sicherheit sorgten zwischen ostblock und
nato bei keiner ein krieg wagte führen
sie jetzt dazu dass ein land ein anderes
quasi zerstören kann nicht alle anderen
haben angst
naja es war auch in zeiten des kalten
krieges denken sie nur an budapest und
156 der aufstand in ungarn denken sie an
prag 68 es war auch in zeiten des kalten
krieges das diktat der nuklearwaffen da
und man kann sich das weg wünschen aber
und eine verantwortliche regierung eine
verantwortliche führung muss ich diesen
fakten stellen man kann sich aber zum
wissensfragen habe in der vergangenheit
fehler gemacht wurden ob es war schon
ein fehler war zu putzen zu sagen wir
greifen auf keinen fall ein und ob es
nicht noch viel mehr ein fehler war sich
derartig abhängig von ihm zu machen vor
allem deutschland stichwort gasgeschäfte
ja das habe ich ehrlich gesagt nie
verstanden dass man sie ihnen auge sich
in diese abhängigkeit begeben hat und
dafür jetzt einen entsprechend hohen
preis zu bezahlen hat die
energieabhängigkeit das war alles andere
als nötig
wo menschen handeln werden fehler
gemacht aber das ist schon ein sehr sehr
großer strategischer fehler gewesen ja
ja sie haben ja damals auch mit dem
nabucco pipeline versucht ein
konkurrenzprojekt den gang zu bringen
was dann am ende auch auf scheiterte
aber sie kennen sich ja immer noch gut
mit dem gasgeschäft aus ist das auch
ihre einschätzung dass wir es uns nicht
leisten können jetzt den gashahn
wirklich gesprochen zuzudrehen und von
einem tag auf den anderen auf das
russische erdgas zu verzichten dass das
so katastrophale wirkungen hätte
das weiß ich nicht das da müssen wir den
verantwortlichen in der bundesregierung
vertrauen dass sie uns hier die
richtigen informationen geben und ich
kann das aus eigener kompetenz nicht
beurteilen verstehen sie denn warum
gehört oder immer noch an dieser männer
freundschaft die sie als sein vize
kanzler auch am end beim entstehen
beobachten konnten fest hätten
da fragen sie den falschen das müssen
sie gerhard schröder fragen ich nicht
aber sie haben ja vielleicht ne meinung
dazu
ich würde mich dazu nicht äußern ich bin
völlig anderer auffassung in dieser
frage schon immer gewesen und
habe sieben jahre gut zusammengearbeitet
und
ich möchte mich dazu nicht äußern dann
blicken wir noch mal nach vorn welche
rolle kommt china in diesem konflikt zu
was ist ihre einschätzung und ihre
informationen dazu
china versucht natürlich seine
interessen zu wahren werden solange
putin festhalten sondern das ihren
interessen entspricht auf der anderen
seite werden sie ja auch sehr sorgfältig
darauf achten dass sie
die wichtigsten
export pressen usa und europäische union
nicht verlieren also eine komplizierte
situation und sie müssen sehr acht geben
dass sie den richtigen zeitpunkt nicht
versäumen in dem sie sich dann endgültig
position und wenn wir uns jetzt die
weltkarte angucken dann haben wir china
hin möchte man eigentlich auch nicht als
supermacht und beherrschend in seiner
nachbarschaft haben wir haben russland
das ist seine alte imperialen ambitionen
auslebt wir haben einen usa die unter
trump plötzlich mit der nato nichts mehr
zu tun haben wollte wer weiß was
irgendwann wiederkommt was bedeutet das
eigentlich für uns europäer
was ist aus unserer europäischen
friedensordnung geworden
man könnte es schlicht und
hart sagen die hat putin
beendet für das erste und es wird sehr
stark auf die geschlossenheit die so
groß ist wie noch nie ich kann mich
nicht daran erinnern dass ein zu hohes
maß an europäische geschlossenheit gibt
und zwar nicht nur innerhalb der eu
sondern auch mit staaten die nicht
mitglied der europäischen union sind die
europäer haben das gefühl dass
berechtigte gefühl
dass putin mit dem angriffe auf die
ukraine mit der aggression auf die
ukraine uns alle meint und entsprechend
ist die reaktion dieses muss meines
erachtens setzt gerade in europäischen
union dann in eine neue politik
umgesetzt werden und dass die
bundesregierung
entschlossen gehandelt hat mit
unterstützung auch
der unionsparteien das finde ich von
überragender bedeutung wir werden in
zukunft und mehr um unsere eigene
sicherheit kümmern müssen allerdings
sagt eines aus natürlich bleibt der
frühere bundesaußenminister
herr fischer danken für das gespräch
militärisch selbstständiger werden und
energiepolitisch unabhängiger das sind
gleich zwei mammutaufgaben für die
nächsten jahre und jahrzehnte heute sind
sicher praktisch alle darüber einig das
ist ein gewaltiger strategischer fehler
gleich mehrere bundesregierungen war
sich bei gas und öl so abhängig zu
machen von russland ein sogenanntes
privatwirtschaftliches projekt waren
diese pipelines für putin nie und so
muss jetzt ein grüner minister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz vor allem zu
sehen wie er bevölkerung und industrie
in den nächsten monaten gewissermassen
mit dem nötigsten versorgt fast könnte
man sagen haben ist jetzt minister für
kriegswirtschaft andreas weise berichtet
ein minister auf erdgassuche robert
habeck in norwegen nach russland der
zweit wichtigste gaslieferant europas
doch die lücke die einen wegfall von
erdgas aus putins reich reißen würde
könnten auch die norweger nicht allein
schließen
[Musik]
vor jahren haben wir uns entschieden auf
russisches gas öl und kohle zu setzen
und wir wollen jetzt so schnell wie
möglich davon wieder weg das ist bei öl
und kohle möglich da haben wir schon
einige erfolge erzielt doch beim gas ist
das etwas schwieriger
gas und erdöl aus den tiefen der tiger
durch viele pipelines kommen sie nach
deutschland nach europa
einfach abschalten quasi den hahn
zudrehen das könnte schneller gehen als
viele denken auf beiden seiten
wir haben ja auch in der vergangenheit
gesehen dass man diese pipelines dann
auch von einem auf den anderen tag
stoppen kann
ölpipelines ebenso und ja wenn die
schiffe dann muss mir vor anker gehen in
europäischen häfen dann ist eben auch
die ölversorgung gestoppt also das würde
quasi über nacht gehen dass man da
aufhört aus russland oder gas zu
beziehen vor allem beim erdgas ist die
abhängigkeit besonders groß mehr als die
hälfte kommt aktuell aus russland die
unabhängigkeit wäre möglich so eine
stellungnahme der nationalen akademie
der wissenschaften leopoldina in halle
doch einfach wird das nicht
für die stromversorgung kann man sich am
leichtesten von russischen gas abhängen
in dem man zusätzliche kohle verwendet
das ist zwar unschön aber es
funktioniert und dann hat man zwei große
blöcke für das für die wir gas verwenden
nämlich in der häuser heizung und für
die industrie anwendungen und dafür
reicht das von anderen quellen zur
verfügung stehende gas für eine seite
also entweder häuser heizen oder
industrie was nicht für beides zusammen
vor allem flüssiges erdgas soll helfen
solche lücken zu schließen dort sind
auch noch kapazitäten zu haben doch
terminals um dieses gas anzunehmen gibt
es in deutschland noch nicht europäische
nachbarn müssten da aushelfen lange zu
lange galt russland als berechenbarer
partner wir sind eigentlich ein land was
was produkte exportiert die sehr
energieintensiv sind und gleichzeitig
sind ein land was selber relativ wenig
eigene energie hat und dass es andere
für sich paradox aber das ist unmöglich
geworden dadurch dass man diese sonder
beziehungen zur russischen gas- und
öllieferungen hatte noch liefern sie die
hauptadern der energieversorgung für
deutschland für europa eine davon heißt
druschba russische freundschaft eine
energie beziehung die viele hierzulande
gern schnell auf kündigen würden
jetzt erstmal die nachrichten
der bundestag hat sich erstmals mit den
geplanten änderungen am
infektionsschutzgesetz befasst der von
appel koalition eingebrachte
gesetzentwurf sieht ein weitergehendes
ende der bundesweit geltenden
schutzmaßnahmen vor so sollen die länder
ab sonntag einen sogenannten basisschutz
anordnen können dazu zählt die masken
pflicht in altenheimen krankenhäusern
und öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln sowie
eine testpflicht etwa in schulen und
kitas und mit hotspot regelungen soll es
die möglichkeit für weitreichendere
maßnahmen wie etwa die masken pflicht
jene konzepte und zugangsbeschränkungen
geben
und so sind die korona zahlen vom robert
koch institut für deutschland dem rk
wurden 262
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet das sind 46 1739 mehr als vor
einer woche 269 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incident sollte einen
neuen höchstwert erreicht und liegt bei
7,1
in japan sind bei einem schweren
erdbeben mindestens ein mensch getötet
und 69 verletzt worden ministerpräsident
key china zufolge gibt es allerdings
keine störungen an den atomkraftwerken
des landes die erdstöße am späten abend
hatten die stärke 7,3 das epizentrum lag
in der provinz fukushima dort hatte nach
einem verheerenden beben vor fast genau
elf jahren ein tsunami zu einer
reaktorkatastrophe geführt nach dem
beben heute waren vorübergehend mehr als
zwei millionen haushalte ohne strom
die britisch iranischen
staatsbürgerinnen dass anita radcliffe
ist wieder auf freiem fuß nach sechs
jahren gefangenschaft in iran mit ihr
kam ein weiterer britisch iranischer
doppelstaatler frei ihr die beiden bei
der ausreise über oman sage radcliffe
war 2016 bei einem familienbesuch mit
ihrer tochter festgenommen und dann der
spionage bezichtigt worden insbesondere
die usa hatten iran vorgeworfen sie als
politische geiseln zu benutzen
pandemie energiewende und jetzt noch
krieg mit erheblichen militärausgaben in
den nächsten jahren das muss auch alles
natürlich finanziert werden und so
ergeht es finanzminister christian
lindner nicht anders als seinen
koalitionspartnern er steht nun auch
quasi über nacht vor einer neuen
ausgangslage
kurz nach seiner amtseinführung hatte er
noch gesagt er sehe sich als
ermöglichung minister doch wie viele der
ursprünglichen vorhaben werden überhaupt
noch möglich sein zugleich hat der
finanzminister ein neues projekt aus der
taufe gehoben hilfe für die autofahrer
frankenfeld richtet
seit tagen kennen sie nur eine richtung
die spritpreise explodieren alle wollen
entlasten von steuersenkungen aber hält
der finanzminister nicht zu langsam zu
bürokratisch linda schlägt staatlich
finanzierte rabatte vor direkt an der
tankstelle andere länder tun das bereits
wir brauchen eine in der breite wirksame
maßnahmen vom pendler über die familie
bis hin zu den kleineren
gewerbetreibenden alle in dieser
situation schnell zu entlasten im
kabinett hat linden heute seinen ersten
bundeshaushalt vorgelegt darin
enthaltenen entlastungen der bürger bei
der eeg-umlage und steuern auch der
heizkostenzuschuss zum wohngeld
nach zwei krone haushalten mit
rekordverdächtiger neuverschuldung sinkt
die nettokreditaufnahme nominell nun auf
99,7 milliarden euro
2023 will lindner die schuldenbremse
wieder einhalten aber mit dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf die ukraine hat sich die welt noch
einmal verändert und nun müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass auch zusätzliche
belastungen auf den bundeshaushalt
zusätzliche
ausgaben auf uns zukommen werden wieviel
sei kaum zu kalkulieren sagt der
minister und kündigt einen ergänzungs
haushalt an so sollen unter anderem
weitere hilfen gegen hohe energiepreise
finanziert werden taschenspielertricks
sagt die linke
starrsinnig verteidigt er wirklich die
ökonomisch absolut unsinnige schwarze
null und krisenlasten schuldenbremse das
ist nicht miteinander vereinbar das ist
die quadratur des kreises
scharfe kritik auch an 100 milliarden
paket für die bundeswehr das sind dann
zusätzlich plant ein sondervermögen
deshalb zählt es trotz finanzierung über
neue kredite bei der schuldenbremse
nicht mit
das geld soll die bundeswehr fit machen
für die zukunft die bundesregierung will
es mit einer grundgesetzänderung gegen
zweckentfremdung absichern dafür aber
braucht sie die unterstützung der union
und die ist noch nicht überzeugt wir
haben gestern erstmals informationen
bekommen wie diese sondervermögen
ausgestaltet werden soll und einmal am
anfang zu stimmen und dann keinen
einfluss mehr auf das haben was danach
passiert das ist nicht das was wir uns
vorgestellt haben mitreden wollen auch
die koalitionspartner die grünen vor
allem beim energie- und klimapaket tank
rabatte für autofahrer das geht ihnen
gegen den strich jetzt nicht auf eine
verbrauchs prämie zu setzen sondern auf
maßnahmen die auch im bereich
energiesparen und energieeffizienz
wirken ich glaube all das findet sich im
moment in dem vorschlag von herr lindner
noch nicht wieder über den geplanten
ergänzungs haushalt mögliche
entlastungen und das geld für die
bundeswehr dürfte im bundestag deshalb
noch heftig diskutiert werden
für staatsverschuldung wie auch für
private schulden steht die entwicklung
der zinsen natürlich immer im fokus
damit jedes mal zweiter in den usa gab
es am abend die mit spannung erwartete
entscheidung der notenbank fed zur
weiteren geldpolitik stichwort zinswende
der leitzins wurde um 0,25 prozentpunkte
angehoben von bethmann welche
auswirkungen hat dieser schritt mehr
zunächst hat die amerikanische notenbank
nur eines im sinn die preise müssen
runter die us-verbraucherpreise waren
zuletzt mit fast 8 prozent so stark
gestiegen wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr
das anheben der zinsen soll die
preistreibende nachfrage nun dämpfen
eine zäsur für die ein halbherzig sagen
die anderen die fed läuft der
inflationsdynamik hinterher sagt zb
ökonom friedrich heinemann die
zentralbank muss jetzt vermeiden dass
aus einer temporären corona und kriegs
inflation ein längerfristiger inflations
prozess wird dafür sind weit höhere
zinsen unausweichlich wie schwierig aber
der spagat für die notenbanken ist
machte eine andere zahl deutlich die fed
korrigierte am abend ihre
konjunkturprognose stark nach unten
nicht zuletzt weil jede anhebung der
zinsen nicht nur die teuerung bekämpft
sie droht auch immer das wachstum zu
sprechen trotzdem fordert die deutsche
wirtschaft steigende leitzinsen auch bei
uns die ezb sollte diesem signal folgen
sagt bga-präsident die an dura in europa
muss ein zeichen gegen die steigende
geldentwertung gesetzt werden der dax
setzt heute auch ein zeichen steigt um
über 500 punkte auf am ende 14 1441
zähler vor allem spekulation um eine
waffenruhe in der ukraine sorgen für den
zweitgrößten anstieg des barometers in
diesem jahr dank wittmann vielen dank
in der fußball bundesliga gab es am
abend ein nachholspiel mainz hat zu
hause gegen dortmund 0 zu 1 verloren vor
dem spiel hatte es im stadion eine
gedenkminute für egidius braun gegeben
der ehemalige dfb chef starb im alter
von 97 jahren an der spitze des
deutschen fußball bundes stand der
unternehmer aus aachen von 1992 bis 2001
bekannt wurde er aber nicht nur als
funktionär sondern auch für sein
soziales engagement und projekte wie die
mexiko-hilfe besonders wichtig war ihm
die verbindung von amateur- und
profifußball brown sagte wenn die wurzel
darauf stirbt die krone
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
168 16 19 40 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
das was man heute schon mal das
auslandsjournal gleich im anschluss
widmet sich ausführlich dem ukraine
krieg unter anderem mit einem porträt
von präsident selent ski und nur noch 45
gibt es dann unser heute schnell update
mit gundula gause und darin auch ein
interview mit der saarländischen spd
spitzenkandidatin und stellvertretende
ministerpräsidentin kariya diesen morgen
wieder da auf wiedersehen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter frische daten von der nasa über
den vergangenen februar sind
reingekommen und die zeigen vor allem im
vergleich zu 1951 bis 1980 vor der
größeren erhitzung eine enorme
temperaturabweichung über europa über
asien und über der arktis teilweise sie
temperaturabweichungen über acht grad so
die aktuellen daten der nasa der schaum
aus wetter und da gibt es zwei hoch die
werden sich zum wochenende verbinden
dann haben wir ein sehr umfassendes hoch
mit 1050 hektopascal
vorher ist dieses tief noch zugange und
schiebt eine kaltfront über uns hinweg
und dementsprechend gibt es in der nacht
schon ganz im westen erste regenwolken
nach osten klar zu auf auch richtung
südosten und das bei tiefsten
temperaturen von null bis minus 2 grad
leichter frost im osten und plus 9 grad
am niederrhein morgen dann am vormittag
ganz im westen regenwolken die langsamen
ostwärts ziehen ansonsten aber viel
sonnenschein im osten und auch richtung
bayern zum nachmittag schieben sich
diese regenwolken dann in die mitte und
richtung ostsee dahinter lockert es
wieder auf und die sonne kommt hervor
temperaturen höchstwerte von 8 bis 13
grad im westen hier also eine deutlich
kühlere luftmassen als zum beispiel im
osten oder im südwesten hier
temperaturen bis 18 grad sonnenschein
gibt es in den nächsten tagen sehr viel
vor allem im westen dann am freitag bei
8 bis 15 grad samstag ebenfalls
weiterhin viel sonne bei 8 bis 14 grad
damit ein schöner abend